today was the day where we find out
which rules pass which rules don't which
ones are tabled which usually means that
we're never going to hear from them
again but but sometimes sometimes they
resurface
one of the things that passed that as of
earlier this week peter king said he
wasn't so sure it would this half
measure
for
incorporating
video technology into getting calls
right i'm a firm believer in booth
umpire i've been for years an advocate
of adding a member to the officiating
crew in black and white stripes sitting
in the booth seeing everything we see at
home and talking to the officials about
any and all mistakes they make just like
and with the same powers of someone
who's on the the on-field crew what the
nfl has approved today sheree is
enhancement to the replay assistance
functions and specifically
the replay assistant will advise the
on-field officials on quote specific
objective aspects of a play when clear
and obvious video evidence is present or
to address game administration issues
now this means catching pass
feed inbounds objective things not hey
the guy from the rams just blew up the
guy from the saints and it was past
interference and you didn't throw a flag
you better throw a flag that's what i'd
like to have them
able to do
under this expansion of the replay
assistance function shireen that still
is not fixable
well you know peter wrote in his column
that the reason it might not pass is
there was a lot of confusion about
exactly how much leeway the replay
assistant was going to have and i'm
still confused about it how much power
this person is going to have they're not
part of the crew so are they going to
feel comfortable calling down or doing
whatever they do and how much are they
going to do that and is it going to vary
stadium by stadium which i guarantee you
it is where
if you have the the booth umpire as a
part the sky judge as part of that team
they're gonna do that now i talked to
troy vincent two years ago when this
first came up mike and we were
proponents of it and still are i talked
to troy vincent a long time about it
after the competition committee meeting
and the two things he said that the
reason that officials don't like it or
the competition committee hasn't pushed
for it one reason is who are those
replay officials like how do you go out
and find them everybody wants to be an
on-field official so do you get retired
officials that's probably the route you
go are there enough of those guys to do
that to join all those crews so there
was a concern about exactly who those
sky judges were going to be and then the
second thing was they're now part of the
crew and how comfortable are they going
to be overturning the guy on the field
but or female on the field whoever it is
the official on the field but hey don't
make mistakes on the field that's what
that person is there to do to correct it
i mean let's get it right and if you err
let's get that fixed if i make an error
i want you to tell me hey you made an
error and i fixed this let's get it
right let's not worry about who's making
the correct call let's just get the call
right mike
well and i still think the referee would
be in charge and have finals say i don't
think you give ultimate authority over
the on-field officiating to the booth
umpire or sky judge whatever rule that
you would apply it's just the benefit of
the perspective that millions at home
have that continues to be a disconnect
it must be addressed by the nfl you've
got seven people who see it one way and
you've got millions who see it another
way
those people at home are the ones who
are reacting to these calls so if you
have someone with a thorough knowledge
of the rules with the authority to speak
directly to the referee just like when
we see them on the field caucusing all
the time we see groups of officials
together and they're talking about this
and they work it out just like that
image right there they're working it out
they're talking about it before they
make a decision the booth
umpire sky judge talks to all of them or
could push the button like the producers
do with us you decide who you're going
to talk to talk to the referee talk to
everyone at once talk to the field judge
you can hit the button and talk to that
person and only that person if you need
to but there's a way to do it that
doesn't undermine the authority of the
referee there's a way to do it that
takes advantage of the skills the
knowledge the abilities of some older
referees on field officials who no
longer are physically able to do it but
still want to be involved like an ad
hocule and shireen i
i hate to say it but i if i really hated
to say it i wouldn't say it i'm going to
say it it's about money at some level
it's about money they don't want to pay
they don't see the incremental benefit
for the money that they put into having
17 additional employees who would be
paid
officiating salary part of the union now
we got to deal with this it's going to
cost us more money how much better
are things going to be
for the extra money that we put in when
we can just instead lump additional
duties onto the replay of system they're
already there they're already getting
paid and and i heard from somebody who
who
knows very well the inner workings of
the officiating department the replay
assistant's already got enough to do
this isn't going to help that person do
their job better and that confusion
about replay assistant versus the
command center you know there's already
some authority that al river on or his
designee has over administrative issues
where does the line get drawn between
what the replay assistant does and what
they do in the league office what if the
replay assistant's getting it wrong when
does the league office get involved i i
just i don't like this because
it's still creates the opportunity for a
debacle
and eventually the next debacle there's
going to be one the next one whichever
one it is is going to be one
that results in millions of dollars
changing hands via legally wagered bets
it's going to get politicians up in arms
it's going to get a criminal prosecution
launched
someone correct you don't need any of
that
if you take care of your own backyard if
you make sure these things don't happen
if you make sure these problems don't
arise in an era where there are 30 35 40
states with legalized gambling and we're
heading that way you don't have that
blow back that's what they need to be
worried about and i'm stunned they're
not more concerned about that if they
were we'd have a booth umpire
and you know what mike they didn't learn
their lesson they had an opportunity to
do that the 2018 as we know nfc
championship game ended as it should not
have ended they didn't get the call
right they didn't throw a flag on
obvious past interference that didn't
happen and you would think they would
have done something at that point to fix
it so what did they do they put in oh
we'll review past interference for a
year and they did that and that went
away and everybody seems to have
forgotten
what happened anybody outside of new
orleans anyway seems to have forgotten
what happened in that game they got it
wrong mike the saints probably would
have gone on to the super bowl they
didn't get to go because of that call
and i just think that it's time that the
nfl fixes this before this happens in a
super bowl when there is an even bigger
uproar than there was in that game mike
and
it wasn't just
something that they tried and decided we
don't like it it was a disaster when
they made past interference calls and
non-calls offensive and defense subject
to replay review because it was poorly
implemented it i never felt like they
had a cohesive set of rules as to how
specific in particular the scrutiny
applied by al river rome was going to be
and i remember when we started to hear
about how he was interpreting past plays
and how those plays would have been
changed if replay review was available
and he was being very technical very
specific looking for clear and obvious
evidence of impairment of the
opportunity of the defensive player or
the offensive player to make that play
on the ball and it was like oh my gosh
that's that no that's not what this
should be for this should be for the
truly egregious know it when you see it
call that's missed so now i think
they've gone the other way and what
they've decided shireen is what i feared
they were going to decide in the
aftermath of the rams saints debacle
by the time it happens again i'll be
gone i think that's the attitude each
individual in this has it's not going to
happen again anytime soon and i'm
willing to roll the dice that this is a
mess that i won't personally have to
deal with someone else
years from now hopefully decades from
now will be the one that has to deal
with that mess we'll let them clean it
up we're just going to assume that what
happened to the ram saints game is a
once in a hundred year
problem
that by the time it happens again we'll
all be dead i i feel like that's the
attitude that finally was adopted by the
competition committee and ownership
generally let somebody else deal with
this problem because we don't want to
spend the money to do it right we don't
feel compelled to do it right because
we're not going to get stung again the
odds are we're not going to have this
problem anytime soon
yeah
frankly mike all they're worried about
is the postseason games right if it
happens in the regular season yeah it's
an uproar big deal it's it's one game
it's a regular season game you throw
that out the door not a big deal so they
need it not to happen in the postseason
and you're right they're just rolling
the dice now that it's not going to
happen that it eventually when it does
happen they're long gone and they may be
right and we may not see this for
another 10 years or 20 years or whatever
but they are rolling the dice that this
could happen and there could be a bad
call that's not fixable in a super bowl
i think a prime time regular season game
with a big audience could be a problem i
think if it's tucked into the one
o'clock eastern games it goes unnoticed
the horrendous phantom
roughing the passer call against the
lions in the vikings game week 17 last
year nobody noticed nobody cared it was
it was horrendous and if it happened in
a game that anybody actually cared about
it would have been a major major major
uproar um
i'll say
this
i believe in following the rules as
written because otherwise why have the
rules but
i also believe that al riveron or
someone else should have on the wall
the emergency brake glass that they can
use
when absolutely necessary to fix what
what obviously will be
a major controversy the next day and
beyond and i've said this before if all
alright had done in that ram saints game
is buzzed in and said drop a flag wait
what do you mean just trust me
we're all going to be better off if you
drop a flag call defensive pass
interference you can thank me later
he was too
rigid in following the rules
you know one of the best things about
knowing the rules is knowing when to
break the rules and if he had done that
we wouldn't need we wouldn't we wouldn't
be having a discussion about replay
assistant or sky judge or booth umpire
there wouldn't have been a year where
there was this shifting bizarre standard
as to what past interference on replay
review was or wasn't so maybe maybe now
between the replay assistant
and the league office being involved in
having a voice maybe what this means
is that
if there is another ram saints
horrendous and on call somebody will say
something to someone and it'll get fixed
in a way that doesn't technically comply
with the rules but that avoids the
disaster i i root for that outcome if it
ever comes to that and of course we'll
never know and we shouldn't know i'm
fine with it as long as they avoid that
debacle
yeah and the thing is mike if they had
dropped that flag even if they drop it
late in the ram saints game the rams are
not going to have an argument with that
other than hey that was a really late
flag yeah it was a late flag but you
know what it was the right call so
they're not going to have much of an
argument and you're right there is a
time to break the rules that was it they
didn't do it and now we're still here
trying to fix this problem from three
years ago trying to figure out how not
to let that happen again and this is a
half-baked idea that they've come up
with to try to fix that problem and
maybe next time they'll throw the flag
maybe they'll do that let's hope
i guarantee you if it had come out in
the aftermath of that game that they had
violated protocol to have the league
office al river on contact
the
referee and say drop a flag if that had
come out it wouldn't have been a big
what would the rams have done would they
have would they have boycotted watching
the super bowl in la the way they
boycotted new orleans no because they
got away with something they shouldn't
have gotten away with how can you be
upset about it if the rules get fudged
in a way to keep you from getting an
unfair outcome so i agree with you and
hopefully that's what will happen the
next time the next time there's an
onside kick in an nfl game there'll be a
better chance of the kicking team
recovering in lieu of enacting that
fourth and 15 proposal that i frankly
love i think they should use the fourth
and 15 play for all kickoffs what
they're doing is limiting the number
of players on the receiving team that
can be in that setup zone between 10 and
25 yards from
the
spot where the ball is kicked the
maximum is now nine usually you've got
10 or 11 defensive players so it's a
numbers game one or two fewer bodies
maximum of nine trying to receive it
maybe there's a better chance that the
kicking team will recover because of the
configuration changes that have been
made in an effort to reduce injuries
during regular kickoff plays and onsite
kickoff plays i mean the onside kickoff
in the old days was
a car crash galore it was 11 guys
crashing into 11 guys and somebody
trying to get their hands on the
football so shireen i don't know how
it's going to work they want the kicking
team they want the team that's trailing
to have a better chance to get back into
the game they're going to try this and
my guess is if we don't see
a noticeable increase in the opportunity
for the team that's kicking that onside
kick to recover the ball that's when
fourth and 15 becomes a viable option
i'm still surprised they haven't adopted
it because i talked to somebody several
months ago who thought that fourth and
15 was gonna make it and this may be the
last ditch alternative before fourth and
15 becomes a reality
i'm not surprised mike these owners are
so conservative like they see that as an
xfl play we're not putting that in our
game you know i'll be surprised if
fourth of 15 ever passes i think it
would be fun i think it would be great i
would love to see it i don't know that
it ever passes we'll see what happens
with this if the percentages go up so
since they've done away with the running
start on kickoffs in 2019 there were 63
on-site kicks eight were recovered last
season 27 on sidekick three were
recovered and you remember that dallas
atlanta game they had the watermelon
kick and the cowboys recovered and came
back it was an exciting game unless
you're a falcons game a falcons fan it
was an exciting game a great finish if
the cowboys hadn't gotten that onside
kick they had no chance to win that game
to come back and i think that's what we
all like seeing unless it's your team
that's being come back on you love
seeing those comebacks you love it come
down to the wire the team that's
trailing to have a chance to win and and
give them a chance to get those onside
kicks and i do think this will help
those percentages go up we'll see as the
year goes on if there's more than that
next year then i think we stay
with this in coming years if it doesn't
maybe they do consider the fourth and 15
and we do go to that which again i would
love to see it mike i think it would be
an exciting play in football you can
only do it probably a certain number of
times maybe just once a game but it
would be so exciting to to see that play
uh in the league in lieu of the onside
kick
roger goodell was asked several years
ago which team he roots for he said the
team that's trailing the nfl wants those
exciting games we saw a lot of
double-digit comebacks last year i think
because stadiums were empty whether
you're trailing or whether you're ahead
and you're if you're whether you're the
visiting team and you don't have to
worry about the crowd noise or the home
team you don't have to worry about the
booing that ensues we saw a lot of those
swings in the nfl loves that when the
team that's down 14 21 however many
points has a chance to come back
single digits will be
in high demand in nfl locker rooms now
that the proposal which kind of came out
of the blue a few weeks ago from the
kansas city chiefs passed easily as
peter king suggested it would
running backs receivers tight ends
linebackers defensive backs all can now
wear single digit numbers the caveat
that we posted today though
if there's already an inventory of your
current number
and you want to change now you're going
to pay for that unsold inventory of
jerseys we'll see how badly some of
these guys want it adrian peterson
wanted to change his number a few years
back and he found out what it was going
to cost to do and he said i'll just i'll
stick with i'll stick with the number i
have thank you very much so we'll see
how that goes but beyond that there's
going to be
maybe rock paper scissors there's going
to be all sorts of competition within
locker rooms to see who gets those
single digit numbers because there's
gonna be a lot of guys who want them
there's gonna be guys who wanna take
them from punters and kickers there's
gonna be guys who maybe wanna take them
from backup quarterbacks that part of
it's gonna be fun to see play out
shireen
yeah and players coming into the league
mike they'll now have a chance to select
those numbers especially you know we
know number two is going to be very
popular with the rams couple guys have
already said they want number two so
maybe they have rock paper scissors to
determine who gets number two and uh
with the rams but yeah i think that's an
interesting thing you wrote about though
having to buy that inventory and how
many of those jerseys are left but mike
what happens to those jerseys do the
players then get those jerseys and get
to sell them himself or give them out or
how does that work
i assume if i paid for them i'm getting
them and you're right if i want to
autograph them and sell them i'll sell
them i'll do whatever i want with them
but if i got to pay for them i'll want
them gimme them even though they're not
nearly as valuable as the jerseys that
have the guys current number you know
another wrinkle to this too a topic we
talked about several weeks back when jj
watt joined the arizona cardinals
what happens if there's a star player
who wants to wear a single digit number
that just so happens to be
retired
by the team
that that player plays for we know about
retired jersey numbers they're retired
until they're not and that is something
and actually i have an idea now
hopefully i'll remember to do it later
tonight i'm going to go back through and
find all the retired single-digit
numbers for each team and say hey
we we may we may see retired jerseys get
unretired if the former player or his
family members say we give you our
blessing to wear the jersey that
supposedly was never going to be worn
again taunting a point of emphasis this
season
this seems to happen every few years
they don't want fights to happen so
they'll they'll get strict about
taunting whether you spike the ball at
the feet of an opponent or spin the ball
or direct something to you know up an
opponent the throwing up of the deuces
even though tyree kill seems to get away
with that a lot he has been fined for it
they're trying to avoid any type of
altercations on the field i get it my
concern is unless and until they are
truly consistent in calling that foul
giving up 15 yards of field position is
a lot
and you better be this would be a
perfect thing for the booth empire to do
because when you're down in the fray you
may not notice it and i think some guys
are going to get away with it and it's
going to be inconsistent and i'd rather
not see it
yeah well we go back to the super bowl
right antoine winfield got
penalized 15-yard now the game was out
of hand the bucks were going to win that
game but he threw up to the deuces to
tyre kill the reason he did that was you
go back to the regular season game tyree
kill did that to him on one of his
touchdowns one of his three first
quarter touchdowns and he didn't get
fined for it didn't get penalized for it
so
that was my question why wasn't tyreek
hill penalized or are fined for this and
you go to the super bowl and it happens
and of course it's from a lot a lot more
people are watching the game and see it
and and respond to it but yeah they need
to be consistent however they do it let
them all get away with it or or penalize
them all but yes it's it's going to be
mike i think some inconsistency in this
because there are going to be some
things that you just don't see as an
official trying to see okay did he cross
the goal line oh wait i didn't see him
put up the the peace sign to the player
behind him or whatever the case may be
but i do think we're going to see some
inconsistency with this
two quick points first i think one of
the reasons there's inconsistency is
when you've got seven officials on the
field and typically multiple who are in
position to maybe make that call there's
a reluctance to be what marv levy would
call the over-officious jerk the
embodiment and personification of the no
fun league because it's a big deal and
and that's the other thing too what's
the big deal i get this concern well and
it used to be the the reason for not
allowing the celebrations that the
league re-embraced several years back
well we don't want someone doing
something that's going to make somebody
else upset maybe get him to fight
they're pushing and shoving and hitting
each other every single play if that
doesn't piss them off to the point where
they're going to fight after the play
whether or not a guy dances into the end
zone or throws up the deuces or spikes
the football in the guy's face that
shouldn't make it any worse
it it if anything they should be more
upset about getting blown up at the line
of scrimmage and getting knocked on
their butt then what may happen after
the play ends so i just i i don't i
don't like it i think there should be a
certain amount of it i think these guys
should be trusted to be sufficiently
mature to walk away and if they do take
a swing send them to the locker room
that's the best deterrent for that all
right last one real quickly the proposal
delay head coaching and gm searches has
been tabled for further discussion the
bills proposed delaying the start of
interviews until after the conference
championship and no hires until after
the super bowl there's no good reason to
not do this and i think the teams
looking for coaches would benefit from
being forced to wait for whatever reason
the nfl wants to have that open season
right after the regular season ends
where the teams that stink can go out
and begin interviewing assistants from
the teams that are still playing
creating
unavoidable distractions
for guys who are trying to finish the
job they have while they're focused on
the job they want and it's impossible
for any human being to compartmentalize
those two when you're in a busy playoff
week it's just impossible and that
becomes whether you're going to get that
job that becomes your bigger priority
than getting things ready for your
team's playoff game and and
there's nothing wrong with that that's
just natural someone explained it to me
back during this year's hiring cycle
when the guy comes home
from work
and his spouse
asks him about his day
he's not going to be asked how'd the
game plan go for this week's playoff
game he's going to be asked what have
you heard about that job we may be
getting in that place we may be moving
to and that promotion that you may be
getting that's normal that's natural and
that creates that inherent conflict
shireen and they need to set up a
situation where that conflict isn't
there for the guys who need to do the
jobs they currently have
well and the other thing mike is this
year we saw no coaches beyond the
divisional round get hired right i think
that's hurt eric the enemy over the last
two years and the bucks really benefited
from this because you think about what
their coaches did in the postseason they
would have been down at least one
coordinator and maybe two after what
they did in the postseason both of those
guys might have gotten head coaching
jobs and we might have a couple of other
minority coaches in
in the league if not eric b enemy as
well so i think that's hurt him so i
think it will help those coaches whose
teams year after year after year are
making the championship game and making
super bowls guys from that patriots
staff who who over a 20-year span were
always going that far mike i i think
they were hurt by this so that should
help them too
all right uh let's go ahead and take a
break plenty of stuff there that was
discussed even though there wasn't a lot
of action in rules being passed more
action necessary hopefully the nfl will
make the tweaks that we have suggested
at some point before they have an even
bigger problem
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports